Hey everybody, you're listening to Smartlist, hosted by Jason Bateman, Will Arnett, and myself, Sean Hayes. I know, I wish my voice was more masculine too. This show is about learning through laughter in the brains of people around the world who are far smarter than us three idiots. And each week, one of us brings on a guest who the other two don't know about. So with that, let's jump into the Smartlist rocket ship and let's blast off into the universe together.
大家好，你们正在收听的是由杰森·贝特曼、威尔·阿奈特和我肖恩·海斯主持的 Smartless。我知道，我也希望我的声音能更有磁性一点。这个节目旨在通过笑声，走进世界上那些远比我们这三个笨蛋聪明的人的大脑，去探索和学习。每周，我们每个人都会邀请一位另外两人都不知道的神秘嘉宾。话不多说，让我们登上 Smartless 火箭，一起向宇宙发射升空吧！
Ooh, I think I just turned myself on. I went to seventh grade with Janet Jackson. Are you serious? Did you? Yeah. At a school called Valley Professional. It was a school that was only from 9 a.m. to 12 p.m. so that you had your afternoons free for auditioning.
哦，我觉得我刚刚把自己给逗兴奋了。我上七年级时和珍妮·杰克逊是同学。真的吗？你真是吗？对啊。在一个叫 Valley Professional 的学校。那是一所只有上午 9 点到中午 12 点上课的学校，这样你的下午就可以空出来去试镜。
It was sort of like the back of a gas station on Sherman Way and Vineland, and I'm not sure they were accredited. I think chances are high that they were not accredited. I went to high school with one of the kids. This is not a bit from the original Degrassi junior high. I went to college with, I was piano majors with Craig Robinson from the office. Really? Oh, I knew that.
它有点像 Sherman Way 和 Vineland 交界处一个加油站的后面，而且我不确定他们有没有获得认证。我觉得他们没有获得认证的可能性极高。我上高中时和其中一个孩子是同学。这不是来自原版《迪格拉西初中》里的梗。我和办公室的克雷格·罗宾逊一起上过大学，我们都是钢琴专业。真的吗？哦，我知道这个。
Wait, I knew that. Piano majors together. Yeah. What's a piano major? You major in piano and you don't minor, and I get it, major in major. Oh, oh, oh. Well, there are different ranks. There's different, because I was a piano colonel, but, um, and then...
等等，我知道这个。一起学钢琴专业的。对啊。什么是钢琴专业？就是主修钢琴，没有辅修，我懂，主修中的主修。哦，哦，哦。好吧，有不同的等级。有不同的，因为我是钢琴上校，但是，嗯，然后……
That is so dumb. I can't believe you. Thank you. It's a stupid thing. Of course you're going to laugh. I just watched you, Hayes, because I knew, I knew that would get you. So dumb. Um...
太蠢了。真不敢相信你。谢谢。这是个很蠢的事。你当然会笑了。海斯，我刚才看着你，因为我知道，我知道这会戳中你。太蠢了。嗯……
Who's our guest? Whose guest is it today? Whose guest is it today? Guys, today my guest today grew up in the Bronx. He became interested in astronomy at the age of nine after visiting the Hayden Planetarium, and today... Is this Derek Cheeter? No, it's not Derek Cheeter.
我们的嘉宾是谁？今天是谁的嘉宾？今天是谁的嘉宾？伙计们，今天我的嘉宾是在布朗克斯长大的。他 9 岁时参观了海顿天象馆后，便对天文学产生了兴趣，而今天……这是德里克·切特吗？不，不是德里克·切特。
Close. He is now the director of that same planetarium. And after studying at Harvard, he earned his doctorate from Columbia University. He was awarded the NASA Distinguished Public Service Medal. Sean, you've really done it this time. He's known for his ability to make difficult concepts accessible to every audience will. Sure. Yep.
接近了。他现在是那个同名天象馆的馆长。在哈佛大学学习后，他在哥伦比亚大学获得了博士学位。他被授予了 NASA 杰出公共服务勋章。肖恩，你这次可真是大手笔啊。他以能把高深的概念讲得让所有观众都能听懂而闻名，威尔。当然。没错。
So, guys, we have with us today my favorite astrophysicist of all infinity, Neil deGrasse Tyson. Unbelievable, Sean. What a gift. Hey, guys. What an honor. Thank you so much for being on here. I know this is, uh, very nice of you to come and chat with us today.
所以，伙计们，我们今天迎来了我所有无限时空中最喜欢的的天体物理学家——奈尔·德格拉斯·泰森。难以置信，肖恩。真是份厚礼。嗨，伙计们。太荣幸了。非常感谢你能来这里。我知道这，呃，你今天能来和我们聊天真是太好了。
I want to, you know, do people kind of like jump right in and ask you things about the universe in the same way one might, you know, after discovering someone's a doctor and go, you know, I have a pain in my lower back. Without hesitation. Yeah. Instead of asking you about you first. Yeah. No, I don't care about me.
我想，你知道的，人们是不是那种一上来就会问你关于宇宙的问题，就像人们发现某人是个医生后，可能会说，你知道的，我下背部有点疼。毫不犹豫。是的。而不是先问你个人的事。是的。不，我不在乎我自己。
And as an educator, I don't think who I teach should care about me. That's like cult building. Really? Yeah. So compare these two scenarios. Someone comes up to me saying, hey, aren't you Neil deGrasse? I said, yes. There's more about a black hole in this.
作为一名教育工作者，我认为我教的人不应该在乎我。那就像是搞个人崇拜。真的吗？是的。所以对比这两种情况。有人走过来对我说，嘿，你不是奈尔·德格拉斯吗？我说，是。关于黑洞还有更多内容在这个里。
So that's the perfect educational encounter. The one that's not is, are you Neil Tyson? I said, yes. Oh, what's your favorite color? What's your favorite? And all of a sudden I become the object of their curiosity rather than the universe itself. And in that way I have failed. And you don't like that?
所以那是完美的教育互动。那种不是的互动是，你是奈尔·泰森吗？我说，是。哦，你最喜欢什么颜色？你最喜欢什么？突然之间，我成了他们好奇的对象，而不是宇宙本身。从这个意义上讲，我失败了。你不喜欢那样？
No, it's, it's a failure. No, no, I, I'm just, it's a failure of my educational efforts if I become the object of their interest. That's all. I'll do it. And I'll accommodate it. And at a certain level you feel like you failed in your objective. Must not have made the science interesting enough for them to come at that.
不，这是，这是个失败。不，不，我，我只是觉得，如果我成了他们兴趣的对象，那就是我教育工作的失败。就是这样。我会配合的。我会迁就它。但在某种程度上，你会觉得你在自己的目标上失败了。一定是没能把科学变得足够有趣，才会让他们奔着这个来。
But not knowing you, I would think, you know, all, all I ever see of you. And again, I'm, I'm such a huge fan of yours. And I could hear you talk about all of this crap, which I love for hours. Oh, but the stuff that he spent his life studying, you, you, you've summed up as crap. Thank you, Sean. Yeah. This is, this is why I don't have a PhD. Crap is piled high indeed, that's what the PhD stands for.
但如果不了解你，我想，你知道的，我所看到的关于你的所有一切。再说一次，我真的是你的超级粉丝。而且我可以听你讲这些我超爱的废话，听上好几个小时。哦，但他花了一生时间研究的东西，你，你，你竟然把它总结为废话。谢谢你，肖恩。是的。这就是为什么我没有博士学位。废话确实堆积如山，博士（PhD）代表的就是这个意思。
No, but you know what I'm saying? Like, I, I, I, like, I want to get into that and believe me, you will answer all of my questions. I'm here for you. Yes. But like, when I read that thing that you first became enamored with the universe at nine years old, going to the Hayden Planetarium. And now you're the director of the Hayden Planetarium.
不，但你知道我的意思吗？就像，我，我，就像，我想深入了解这个，相信我，你会回答我的所有问题。我为你而来。是的。但就像，当我读到那个故事，说你九岁时去海顿天象馆，第一次对宇宙着迷。而现在你是海顿天象馆的馆长。
Like most teenagers don't have that drive, you know, when you, because I read that you obsessively studied astronomy when you were a teenager. And so most teenagers don't have that drive, what was the thing that kept you going? I was like, oh my God, the thirst for knowledge. It was the, it wasn't so much a thirst for knowledge, but the fact that I knew that when I looked up, I was completely steeped in ignorance and boundless ignorance. And so there's this quest. Jason usually just looks in the mirror and that happens.
就像大多数青少年都没有那种驱动力，你知道的，当你，因为我读到过你青少年时期痴迷于天文学。所以大多数青少年没有那种驱动力，是什么在支撑着你不断前进？我当时就想，哦天哪，对知识的渴望。与其说是对知识的渴望，不如说是因为我知道，当我抬头仰望时，我完全沉浸在无知和无垠的无知之中。所以这就存在一种探索。杰森通常只是照镜子，然后就会那样。
He is so connected with that thought. I actually sleep with my eyes open. No. You know, the fact that there's something around us that we know about, which we know so little, became this infinite source of curiosity for me. And I've never been the same since age nine. And I didn't know that most people are still sort of ambling in college. What am I going to major in?
他对那个想法太有共鸣了。我其实是睁着眼睛睡觉的。不。你知道，我们周围有些我们知道的事物，而我们对此又知之甚少，这个事实成了我无限好奇的源泉。自从九岁以来，我就再也不是从前那个我了。而我不知道大多数人上大学时还在闲逛。我该主修什么专业？
Oh, you major in astronomy. Was that because it's early in the alphabet? You know, no, my stuff goes deep with regard to that. And to that point, explain to people like us idiots who don't know what the difference between astrophysics and astronomy is. Well, so we're all in modern times do astrophysics. Astronomy is the traditional older name for it. But in the late 1800s, we figured out how to apply the laws of physics to what was going
哦，你主修天文学。是因为它在字母表里比较靠前吗？你知道的，不，我在那方面研究得很深。说到这里，请向我们这些不知道天体物理学和天文学有什么区别的笨蛋们解释一下。好吧，所以我们在现代都在做天体物理学。天文学是它传统的老名字。但在 19 世纪末，我们弄清楚了如何将物理定律应用到宇宙中正在发生的事情中
on in the universe and thus was birth astrophysics. Before then, it's like, well, the star is over here and it's this bright and it's that color. Oh, it might be moving. Okay. So let's call it a planet or it's got a tail. So we call it a comet. This was descriptive in the 19th century.
，于是天体物理学诞生了。在此之前，情况就像是，嗯，那颗星在那边，它这么亮，那是那个颜色。哦，它可能在动。好吧。那我们叫它行星，或者它拖着一条尾巴。所以我们叫它彗星。这是 19 世纪的描述性科学。
We learned how to take spectra of stars and when a spectra breaks the light into its colors like a rainbow. And when you do that, you learn things like how fast is it moving, how fast is it rotating, what it's made of, how long ago it was born, create models of that. And so all of a sudden, the universe becomes our backyard. Yeah. Because, you know, when I still do this, I mean, on the dumbest level on this most, you know, simplest level, there's places on earth and it's wearing thin where the air is cleaner
我们学会了获取恒星的光谱，当光谱像彩虹一样把光分解成各种颜色时。当你这样做时，你就会了解诸如它移动得有多快、它旋转得有多快、它是用什么物质组成的、它是什么时候诞生的，并建立相关模型。于是，突然之间，宇宙成了我们的后院。对啊，因为，你知道的，当我仍然这样做时，我是说，在最笨的层面上，在这个最，你知道的，最简单的层面上，地球上有些地方空气更干净，这种地方已经越来越少了
and you can see more stars, somewhere like Hawaii or whatever. And you lie there and you, like a kid, I'm still act like a kid and I look up and the longer you look up at a clear sky to all the stars, you can't help but think about everything you're talking about, which is where do we come from? That light that we're seeing is like way older than the earth and whatever. That's the one that got me. And when I was about 12 years old, the teacher said to me, he said, look, I would say, you see that star?
，你可以看到更多的星星，比如夏威夷或其他地方。你躺在那里，像个孩子一样，我依然像个孩子一样抬头仰望，你盯着晴朗夜空中的星星看的时间越长，你就越忍不住去想你所谈论的一切，那就是我们从哪里来？我们看到的那些光比地球还要古老得多，诸如此类。就是那个击中了我。当我大约 12 岁的时候，老师对我说，他说，看，我会说，你看到那颗星了吗？
I don't know what I was doing with the teacher in the middle of the night, but he said, the light that you're seeing, that's another episode, it's a different episode, a whole different podcast. That one's called, You Don't Want to Know, on a very special, you don't want to know. So he said, the light you're seeing right now left that star back in the Roman Empire. And I said, well, what does, what does that mean? He says, well, the speed of light is, and correct me if I'm wrong, you're 186,000 miles a second.
我不知道半夜三更我和老师在干什么，但他说，你看到的这光，那是另一集，是另一集，完全不同的播客。那一集叫作《你其实并不想知道》，在一个非常特殊的《你其实并不想知道》里。所以他说，你现在看到的光在古罗马时期就离开那颗星了。我说，嗯，那，那是什么意思？他说，嗯，光速是——如果我错了请纠正我——每秒 186,000 英里。
You got it. So 186,000 miles a second. You just pull that out. Yeah. I mean, he left a mark, hold your jokes, hold your jokes will. So if you travel at 186,000 miles a second for a year, that's a light year. So that's a, so it's a measurement of distance. So he said, so the light traveling at 186,000 miles per second, since the Roman Empire,
完全正确。所以是每秒 186,000 英里。你随口就说出来了。对啊。我的意思是，他留下了印记，别开玩笑了，威尔，别开玩笑了。如果你以每秒 186,000 英里的速度旅行一年，那就是一光年。所以这是一个，所以这是一个距离的度量。所以他说，因此，光以每秒 186,000 英里的速度传播，自古罗马时期以来，
that's how far away that, that, that light is only just now reached, that's correct. Yeah. And he said, and he said, he said, for instance, the sun, the heat that you're feeling on your face, this is, this is after we woke up. He said, he said, he said, he said, that's, and you put down the cigarette to put it out on my forearm and he said that that is seven minutes old, that, that, that heat from the sun. So that's how far the sun is away.
那就是那道光距离我们那么远，直到现在才刚刚到达，对吧？是的。他说，并且他说，他说，例如，太阳，你脸上感觉到的热量，这是，这是在我们醒来之后。他说，他说，他说，他说，那是，然后你放下烟头在我前臂上掐灭，他说那太阳的热量是七分钟前的。所以这就是太阳距离我们有多远。
Okay. I don't know how you got the speed of light correct and that number wrong. Oh. So are you close enough? No. Are you close enough? It's a long night. So it's not seven minutes away.
好吧。我不知道你是怎么把光速弄对而把那个数字弄错的。哦。所以你猜得够近吗？不。你猜得够近吗？这是一个漫长的夜晚。所以它不是七分钟的距离。
I want to give you the correct number. I mean, to know the speed of light to that precision and then get that other number wrong, that's a little weird, but it's eight minutes and 20 seconds, 500 seconds. Wow, it was so close. And by the way, it's not only, it's not only the light that takes eight minutes and 20 seconds to reach us, so too does it take the sun's gravity. So if you're some giant and plucked to the sun out of the middle of the solar system, we would still orbit.
我想告诉你正确的数字。我的意思是，既然能以那种精度知道光速，然后却把另一个数字弄错了，这有点奇怪，但它是 8 分 20 秒，500 秒。哇，太接近了。顺便说一句，不仅是，不仅是光需要 8 分 20 秒才能到达我们这里，太阳的引力也是如此。所以如果你是个巨人，把太阳从太阳系的正中央拔除，我们仍然会围绕它运行。
We would still feel its gravity. We would not know any different for eight minutes and 20 seconds. And at that instant, we would plunge into darkness and fling out into interstellar space. So that is those moments, those things, you know, a teacher telling Jason that thing, those are mind-blowing moments. And I've had those mind-blowing moments where I hear these things, which obviously throughout, because of what you do throughout your life, you must have had a million mind-blowing revelations and stats and things thrown at you and discoveries that you've made.
我们仍然会感受到它的引力。在 8 分 20 秒内，我们不会觉察到任何不同。就在那一瞬间，我们将陷入黑暗，并被甩向星际空间。所以这就是那些时刻，那些事情，你知道的，老师告诉杰森的那件事，那些都是令人大开眼界的时刻。而我也经历过那些让我大开眼界的时刻，当我听到这些事情时，显然贯穿了你的一生，因为你的职业，你一定经历过数百万次大开眼界的启示、统计数据，以及向你抛出的各种发现和你自己做出的发现。
Have you reached a point where it doesn't blow your mind anymore? Or what are the things that blow your mind about the universe around us? So everyone, I think, should have their mind blown at least once a week, okay? The mind-blowing quota, I think, should be about that. And if your mind is blowing, it means you're not reading enough or you're not exploring enough because there's stuff out there. I'll give you, here's a simple one, ready? If you go to the flower of an apple orchard and count how many petals are on that flower,
你有没有达到这样一个地步：这些已经不再让你感到震撼了？或者说，关于我们周围的宇宙，是什么让你感到震撼？所以每个人，我认为，都应该至少每周让自己的大脑震撼一次，好吗？震撼大脑的额度，我觉得应该差不多是这样。如果你的大脑受到了震撼，那就意味着你读的书还不够，或者你探索得还不够，因为外面有太多的东西了。我给你举个例子，来个简单的，准备好了吗？如果你去一棵苹果树的花朵上数一数那朵花上有多少个花瓣，
okay? There are five petals. Then that flower shrivels up and then it becomes the fruit of the tree, the apple. If you cut the apple horizontally through it and you see the chambers, there are five chambers. So there's a correspondence between the number of seed chambers in the apple and the petals on the flower that became the apple. I mean, this is just kind of, if you don't notice that, start noticing it.
好吗？有五个花瓣。然后那朵花枯萎了，接着它变成了树的果实——苹果。如果你把苹果水平切开，看到里面的心，有五个心。所以苹果里的种子心室数量与变成苹果的花的花瓣数量之间存在着一种对应关系。我的意思是，这简直就是，如果你没有注意到这一点，那就开始注意它吧。
And then there are places where, and that's not even anything. That's kind of nothing to do with the origin of the universe, but it's something simple that's around you. I've had a question that I've been waiting to talk with somebody like you to help me try to answer. And it takes a cream, right? You're looking for a cream or an ointment? Or an ointment or a gel.
然后有些地方，这甚至算不上什么。这甚至跟宇宙的起源没什么关系，但这是你身边一些很简单的事情。我一直有一个问题，我一直在等待能和像你这样的人聊聊，好帮我试着解答。需要一种乳霜，对吧？你在找乳霜还是软膏？还是软膏或凝胶。
The, okay, so if you look with a strong enough telescope, you can see further and further back in time, right, because you're seeing light that is older and or new, well, you'll contextualize that for me. But basically, you could effectively look at the big bang. Yeah, the origin of the universe. Exactly. So you are looking at the past and then... By the way, just to be clear, we're in a coronavirus right now, but if I were sitting across the
好，那么，如果你用足够强大的望远镜看，你可以看到更远、更久远的时间，对吧，因为你看到的光更老，或者更新，好吧，你会为我梳理这个概念的。但基本上，你实际上可以回看到大爆炸。对，宇宙的起源。没错。所以你看到的是过去，然后……顺便说一句，为了说清楚，我们现在正处于冠状病毒时期，但如果我坐在你对面，
table from you, you don't see me in your present. You see me in your past. Light at 186,000 miles per second goes one foot per nanosecond, one foot per billionth of a second. So we're like three feet across from each other. You see me not as I am, but as I once was, three billionths of a second ago. We don't make a big deal of that because human lifespan is much longer than billionths of a second.
你看到的并不是现在的我。你看到的是我的过去。光以每秒 186,000 英里的速度传播，每纳秒一英尺，每十亿分之一秒一英尺。所以我们俩相距大约三英尺。你看到的我不是现在的我，而是三亿分之一秒前的我。我们不拿这个大做文章，因为人类的寿命比十亿分之一秒要长得多。
But if I start getting farther and farther, the moon is one and a half light seconds, the sun, 500 light seconds, the nearest star for light years, you keep going farther and farther away. You get to significant time frames back into the past of the object you're observing. And that's why that's where cosmology comes in. It's how we decode the record of the universe because it takes light so much damn time to reach us. And Sean, you were going to take cosmology, right?
但如果我开始离得越来越远，月亮是 1.5 光秒，太阳是 500 光秒，最近的恒星是几光年，你不断地走得越来越远。你会到达回溯到你正在观测的物体的过去的显著时间框架。这就是宇宙学发挥作用的地方。它是我们如何解码宇宙记录的方法，因为光需要该死这么长的时间才能到达我们这里。肖恩，你本来打算选修宇宙学的，对吧？
At one point, just... Yeah, for my skin. Beauty school. For my skin. Yeah. That's why I glow. That's why I glow like a star. Beautifully, yes.
曾经有一段时间，只是……对，为了我的皮肤。美容学校。为了我的皮肤。对啊。这就是我发光的原因。这就是我像星星一样发光的原因。美丽发光，是的。
So if you're looking back at something that happened a long time ago, i.e. the Big Bang, somewhere in that Big Bang is our planet, is the Earth. And therefore, you see the Earth before anything has ever happened on it. No. So if you can see... I'll let you continue, but I should really stop you there, but I'll let you continue. So let's make an assumption that the Big Bang was a start of everything. So at some point, whatever we're rolling around on here on this rock was in there.
所以如果你在回看很久以前发生的事情，也就是大爆炸，那个大爆炸的某个地方就是我们的星球，就是地球。因此，你在地球上从未发生任何事情之前就看到了地球。不对。所以如果你能看到……我让你继续，但我真的应该在那里阻止你，不过我还是让你继续吧。所以我们做一个假设，大爆炸是一切的起点。所以在某个时刻，我们在上面滚来滚去的这块石头就在里面。
So my point is, if you can see all the way back that far, is there a theory? Because it would be impossible to actually construct. Where you could set up a series of mirrors, where you could look back and forth and back and forth and back and forth enough times, theoretically, where you could see yesterday. If we can already see the Big Bang, that's got to be harder than seeing yesterday. But if you constricted that into or contracted that, rather, into a series of mirrors, then maybe you could eventually see last week, last month. Yeah.
所以我的意思是，如果你能一直回看到那么远，有没有这样一种理论？因为实际建造它是不可能的。你可以设置一系列镜子，在那里你可以来回、来回、来回、来回看足够多的次数，理论上，你可以看到昨天。如果我们已经能看到大爆炸，那这一定比看到昨天更难。但如果你把那个压缩进，或者说收缩进一系列镜子里，那么也许你最终能看到上周、上个月。对。
So if you put a mirror one light day away from you and you look at it, you will see yourself yesterday. Right. Okay. But that requires a mirror. The Big Bang is not a mirror. So when you see evidence of the Big Bang that far out, you're not seeing us go through the Big Bang, you're seeing another part of the universe go through the Big Bang.
所以如果你放一面距离你一光日的镜子并看着它，你就会看到昨天的自己。对吧。好的。但这需要一面镜子。大爆炸不是一面镜子。所以当你看到那么远的大爆炸证据时，你并没有看到我们经历大爆炸，你看到的是宇宙的另一个部分在经历大爆炸。
If they looked to where we are, they don't see our light from you right now in this podcast. No. They see Earth and our galaxy 14 billion years ago when we were going through the Big Bang. So you have to be that distance away to see that far in the past. So there is no way to construct a window into the past by setting up a series of well-tuned mirrors. Well, if someone else set that up for you, yeah, so you can set up a mirror seven light days away and then you look at it, you'll see yourself two weeks ago because it's seven
如果他们看向我们所在的地方，他们现在在这个播客里看不到来自你的我们的光。不。他们看到的是 14 亿年前我们经历大爆炸时的地球和我们的星系。所以你必须处于那个距离才能看到那么遥远的过去。因此，不可能通过设置一系列调校良好的镜子来建造一扇通往过去的窗户。好吧，如果别人为你设置好了那个，对，所以你可以设置一面距离七光日的镜子，然后你看着它，你会看到两周前的自己，因为它距离七天远，七天返回。
days out, seven days back. So in theory, like Jason could apologize to me for certain things that he did in theory. Do you think we could set enough mirrors in a row so that we could look far back enough to see the start of Jason's question? No, top scientists still try to try to work on that. I want to go back again. A lot of people don't ask you about you and I'm interested in you as well as all the other stuff.
所以在理论上，比如杰森可以为他在理论上做过的一些事情向我道歉。你觉得我们能把足够的镜子排成一排，从而能够回看足够远以看到杰森提问的开始吗？不能，顶尖科学家仍在努力研究这个。我想再次回到这个话题。很多人不问关于你个人的事，我对你以及所有其他东西都很感兴趣。
And I still want to get to that, but you have two kids, right? Did they ever follow in your passion or do they have, are they on TikTok and that's it? There was never that expectation or obligation and they had freedom to think what they want, to study what they want, and they're each doing different things right now. But I can tell you that by the time they were 12 or 13 certified scientifically literate. Oh, wow. Oh, yeah. You don't have to tell us, but are they in that world of science?
我仍然想谈那个，但你有两个孩子，对吧？他们有没有追随你的热情，或者他们有吗，他们是在玩 TikTok 还是只有这个？从来没有那种期望或义务，他们有自由去思考他们想思考的，去学习他们想学习的，而且他们现在都在做不同的事情。但我可以告诉你，到他们 12 岁或 13 岁时，已经是获得认证的具备科学素养的人了。哦，哇。哦，是的。你不用告诉我们，但他们是在那个科学界吗？
No, no, but they're scientifically literate. So the difference is, if you're scientifically literate means your brain is wired for inquiry. It's wired for thought so that at a young age, I'm happy that they were also polite when they did this because otherwise it would be embarrassing if you were a grown-up, walked into the room and you said something, oh, I checked my horoscope sign today and my 12-year-old, 13-year-old kids heard that. They would say, well, what did you find? They would start asking questions and what are you basing that on and have you tested
不，不，但他们具备科学素养。所以区别在于，如果你具备科学素养，就意味着你的大脑是为了探究而构建的。它是为思考而构建的，所以在他们很小的时候，我很高兴他们在做这件事时也很礼貌，否则如果你是个成年人，走进房间说了一些话，哦，我今天查了我的星座运势，然后我 12 岁、13 岁的孩子听到了，那就会很尴尬。他们会说，哦，你发现了什么？他们会开始问问题，你这是基于什么，你测试过吗？
it? And then just calmly sort of ask the questions to drive you into the corner that you really are in because you have no foundation for those thoughts. That's the science literacy that I'm talking about, that anybody can and should cultivate for themselves, whether or not you become a scientist. Neil, if you could pick one subject that you would have an equal level depth of knowledge about, what would it be? Is there another area?
然后平静地提出类似的问题，把你逼进你真正身处的那种绝境，因为你的那些想法没有任何根据。这就是我所说的科学素养，无论是谁，无论你是否成为科学家，任何人都可以也应该为自己培养这种素养。奈尔，如果你能选择一个你拥有同等级别知识深度的学科，那会是什么？还有其他领域吗？
Thanks for that question. If there's a parallel universe, an alternative, not in this universe, but another universe. In another universe, I would be writing songs for Broadway musicals. Wow. Are you serious? Do you write? Do you play anything? Oh, here it comes.
谢谢你的问题。如果有平行宇宙，另一种选择，不是在这个宇宙中，而是另一个宇宙。在另一个宇宙中，我会为百老汇音乐剧写歌。哇。你是认真的吗？你会写作吗？你会玩什么乐器吗？哦，来了。
No, this is why it's another universe. That's what I said. So I don't have musical ability, but I like to write. I like knowing the effect that words have on your emotions, on your thoughts, on your enlightenment. I like simplifying phrases and good songs are not complex stories. Go read a book if you wanted a complex story. It's got to hit you emotionally.
不，这就是为什么这是另一个宇宙。我就是这么说的。所以我没有音乐才华，但我喜欢写作。我喜欢了解文字对你的情感、你的思想、你的启发所产生的影响。我喜欢简化短语，好歌从来不是复杂的。如果你想要复杂的故事，去读书吧。它必须在情感上打动你。
So my family, we go to musical theater often. I will tear up at a simple Broadway boy meets girl musical or nowadays it's boy meets boy, girl meets girl. What are those where there's the expression of human emotion? Well, thank you for checking out the 2010 smash hit on Broadway promises, promises starring Sean Hayes and Kristen Chenoweth. That's so nice of you. Okay.
所以我的家人，我们经常去看音乐剧。我会为一部简单的百老汇男孩遇上女孩的音乐剧而落泪，或者现在是男孩遇上男孩，女孩遇上女孩。那些表达人类情感的是什么？好吧，谢谢你关注百老汇 2010 年的热门轰动剧作《承诺，承诺》，由肖恩·海斯和克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯主演。你太好了。好吧。
That's incredible. Way to go backstage, Neil. Yeah. So if I had an alternative universe, so I'd like to write. And so when I write my books, each sentence, each phrasing, each turn of the syllables of a word, I'm thinking about how that lands in the reader. I think if it's done well, that's what it should be like because then you'll just want more of it.
太不可思议了。真有你的，还能去后台，奈尔。对啊。所以如果我有一个替代宇宙，我喜欢写作。所以当我写书时，每个句子、每个措辞、每个词的音节转变，我都在考虑它在读者心中是如何着陆的。我想如果写得好的话，就应该是这个样子的，因为那样你会想要更多。
So if there's another universe, that's what I'd be doing in that universe. I have an idea and this is, I'm not being snarky here at all. What if you wrote a space musical, like if you, I could see that would be really interesting if you somehow, I mean, would, would anybody think to make a musical about Hamilton? You know, like that's just bizarre. Yeah, the fascinating fact about Broadway musicals is that they have been on every possible subject you couldn't ever have imagined. But not space.
所以如果有另一个宇宙，那就是我在那个宇宙中会做的事情。我有一个想法，而且这，我绝对不是在阴阳怪气。如果你写一部太空音乐剧会怎么样，如果你，我觉得如果能以某种方式，我的意思是，会有人想到为《汉密尔顿》创作音乐剧吗？你知道的，就像那太离奇了。对，百老汇音乐剧最迷人的事实是，它们涉及了你能想象到的每一个可能的主题。但没有太空。
Hamilton, Cats, the prime minister of Argentina, you know, just, just make the list. How does that even happen? So why don't you, so why don't you do that? Because that's another, didn't I, how did I start this? I said in another universe. But you could be the creative consultant. You're saying he could write the book and somebody else could write the music. Yeah.
《汉密尔顿》、《猫》、阿根廷总理，你知道的，随便列个清单。这到底是怎么发生的？所以你为什么不呢，所以你为什么不那样做呢？因为那是另一个，我不是说过吗？我是怎么开头的？我说在另一个宇宙里。但你可以成为创意顾问。你是说他可以写剧本，别人可以写音乐。对。
I think so. Yeah. I do have some ideas and I have notes in my book, but that's not, I got other, I got the universe. Call Sean. But we're making deals here. But you know, it's funny that you say, Neil, that you say, you know, that they've, they've, there are Broadway musicals based on every conceivable subject of the president of Argentina
我想是的。对。我确实有一些想法，我的书里也有笔记，但我不是，我有别的，我有宇宙。给肖恩打电话。但我们在谈交易。但你知道这很有趣，奈尔，你说，你，你知道的，他们已经，他们已经，有以阿根廷总统为主题的百老汇音乐剧了
with Evita. They're, you know, whatever it is. And that kind of reminded me of, and this whole conversation reminded me of somebody one time explaining to me the idea of infinity. They said, imagine infinity is, imagine a room, imagine a library that is filled with books on every possible subject, including me describing that library to you. There's a book on, about me describing, describing that book to you. There's like, on every possible, there's the effect of me describing that convert, you
，通过《贝隆夫人》。他们有，你知道的，无论是什么。这让我想起了，整个对话让我想起了曾经有人向我解释无穷的概念。他们说，想象一下无穷是，想象一个房间，想象一个图书馆，里面塞满了关于每一个可能主题的书籍，包括我向你描述那个图书馆。有一本书是关于我描述，向你描述那本书的。有这样的，关于每一个可能的，有我描述那个对话对你产生的效果，
know, to you. Oh, we got it. The effect that has on butterflies, like whatever. Understood. Moving forward. Imagine that they're stacked in every direction. Yeah. As far as you can see, they said, that's what infinity is.
你知道的。哦，我们懂了。那对蝴蝶产生的影响，诸如此类。继续。想象一下它们向各个方向堆叠。对。只要你能看到的地方，他们说，这就是无穷。
We got it. No, no, no. The libraries themselves. End it with a question. Will, can I talk to you for a sec? My question is this. No, I got one for you. Let's, let's have, I'll give you a starter infinity, right?
我们懂了。不，不，不。图书馆本身。以一个问题结束。威尔，我能跟你谈一秒钟吗？我的问题是这样的。不，我有一个问题要问你。让我们，让我们，我给你一个入门级的无穷，好吗？
Because it's not really infinity, but it is something to think about. So if consider that if you open a dictionary, every word used in the definition of every word is in that same dictionary. Yeah. That's kind of mind blowing. Yeah. That is interesting. I never thought about that.
因为它不是真正的无穷，但它确实是一件值得思考的事情。所以，考虑到如果你打开一本字典，每个词的定义中使用的每个单词都在那本同一本字典里。对。这有点让人大开眼界。对。这很有趣。我从没想过这一点。
Okay. Now, now the other things that are sort of transcend comprehension, Pinocchio, okay. Here's a sentence that Pinocchio utters, ready? My nose is about to grow. What will happen? It's going to grow. It's going to grow probably. It's not going to grow.
好，现在，现在其他一些有点超越理解的事情，匹诺曹，好吧。这里有一句匹诺曹说的话，准备好了吗？我的鼻子马上要长长了。会发生什么？它会变长。它可能会变长。它不会变长。
It's not going to grow. Pinocchio is a liar. Let me finish. It's not going to grow. That means he was lying. So that's right. So it's not going to grow. No, that means he was telling the truth.
它不会变长。匹诺曹是个骗子。让我说完。它不会变长。这意味着他在撒谎。所以这就对了。所以它不会变长。不，这意味着他说的是实话。
Okay, so let me get to some other questions I have. So my point is that sentence has no meaning in Pinocchio's universe, even though the nouns and verbs are all in the right place. It transcends the world that you have set up to understand Pinocchio's statements and his actions. It's a very simple sentence. Given that we agree upon the rules of Pinocchio. Yes.
好吧，那我来问一些我有的其他问题。所以我的意思是，在匹诺曹的宇宙中，这句话没有任何意义，尽管名词和动词都在正确的位置。它超越了你为理解匹诺曹的言论和行为所设定的世界。这是一句非常简单的句子。鉴于我们认同匹诺曹的规则。对。
Yes. The courts we agree, the courts we agree. Given those rules, this is a sentence that cannot even be uttered in his world. So infinity is something that is not fundamentally accessible to the wiring of our brain because our brain evolved on the plains of the Serengeti to not get chased by a lion, not get eaten by a lion. So the tools we need to not die in our evolutionary past do not include infinity. So based on that, so Neil, so our brains are not wired to understand the concept of,
是的。我们认同的规则，我们认同的规则。鉴于这些规则，这是一句在他的世界里甚至无法说出来的话。所以无穷是某种从根本上来说无法被我们大脑的连线所理解的东西，因为我们的大脑是在塞伦盖蒂平原上进化而来的，目的是为了不被狮子追赶，不被狮子吃掉。所以我们在进化过去中为了不死而需要的工具不包括无穷。基于此，所以奈尔，所以我们的大脑不具备理解这一概念的连线，
fundamentally, to understand the concept of infinity. Yeah, there's an absence of logic. We are logical creatures relative to other life forms, but our capacity to not be logical knows no bounds. But the fact that you know that, and so you have to make certain leaps in order to try to, how do you hack that in order to make discoveries in things that you have to do? What is, do you know, and are you just aware of your own inability to do it simultaneously? It comes from the math.
从根本上讲，无法理解无穷的概念。是的，缺乏逻辑。相对于其他生命形式，我们是有逻辑的生物，但我们缺乏逻辑的能力是没有限度的。但既然你知道这一点，所以你必须做出某些飞跃，以便试图，你如何破解它以便在你必须做的事情中做出发现？是什么，你知道吗，你是否意识到自己同时做到这一点的无能？它来自于数学。
So you do the math long enough, then you absorb the math as part of your intuition. So you can think intuitively about what the math equations would have done, rather than relying solely on how you would have not been eaten by a lion, and the wiring that that provides. So you start building up other wiring in your brain that empowers you to think in these other ways. And this is how you think in the quantum. The quantum world is really weird.
所以你做数学题的时间足够长，然后你就会将数学作为你直觉的一部分吸收进去。因此，你可以直观地思考数学方程会产生什么结果，而不是仅仅依靠你如何才能不被狮子吃掉，以及那种连线所提供的功能。所以你开始在大脑中建立其他连线，使你有能力以这些其他方式思考。这就是你在量子领域思考的方式。量子世界真的很奇怪。
Particles popping in and out of existence. Particles simultaneously existing as a wave, and a wave particle duality you might have heard of this. All of this is fundamental, and the mathematics describes it, the experiments measure it. The brain cannot comprehend it. I know we don't have a lot of time. I have tons of questions. So let's do like, not a rapid fire, but lightning round.
粒子凭空出现又消失。粒子同时作为波存在，以及你可能听说过的波粒二象性。所有这一切都是基础性的，数学描述了它，实验测量了它。大脑无法理解它。我知道我们没有太多时间。我有一堆问题。所以我们来个，不是快问快答，而是闪电轮。
I'm good. I got you. Okay. Let's do it. So how? Boxers or briefs. And by the way, my lightning answers need to be matched with your lightning questions, just to be clear in order for that to work.
我很好。我懂你。好的。我们开始吧。所以，怎么？平角裤还是三角裤。顺便说一句，我的闪电回答需要与你的闪电问题相匹配，为了让它起作用，得说清楚。
No, we're here to listen to you. If you guys have like something to follow, but these are really, I wrote, I wrote these down because I'm going to know, are we ever going to get to Mars and why do we want to? We will if it has geopolitical priorities. But otherwise, I think it's a very distant dream. So if China says they want to put military bases on Mars, we're there in nine months. If not, really, yeah, yeah. We're going to the moon again.
不，我们是来听你说的。如果你有什么要跟进的，但这些真的很，我把这些写下来是因为我想知道，我们什么时候才能去火星，为什么我们要去？如果有地缘政治优先事项的话，我们会去的。否则，我认为这只是一个非常遥远的梦想。所以如果中国说他们想在火星上建立军事基地，我们九个月就能到那里。如果没有，真的，真的。我们要再去月球了。
Is that right? Did I just read that? Yeah. Because other countries are gaining power over what's called CIS lunar space, the space between earth and the moon, and that's the new high ground. So there are geopolitical forces that make all of that happen. The business cases come later, the tourism, then all the rest of this and the SpaceX, that all comes after.
是吗？我刚读到那个吗？对。因为其他国家正在获得对所谓“环月空间”（CIS lunar space，地球和月球之间的空间）的控制权，那是新的制高点。所以有地缘政治力量使这一切发生。商业案例稍后才会出现，旅游业，然后所有其余的以及 SpaceX，这些都是在后面。
The first forays out there are countries who have geopolitical interest in mind. Columbus came to the new world. Was that, did Queen Isabella say, oh, Columbus, take pictures and bring them back and tell us? No. No, it was like, here's a satchel of Spanish flags. Plant them wherever you go and find a shorter trade route to India. It's always been the driver of humanity.
最初涉足那里的，是那些把地缘政治利益放在心上的国家。哥伦布来到了新大陆。是这样的吗，伊莎贝拉女王曾说过，哦，哥伦布，拍些照片带回来告诉我们？没有。不，就像是，这里有一包西班牙国旗。无论你走到哪里都插上它们，并找到一条去印度的更短的贸易路线。这一直是人类的驱动力。
Always, always. So because I'm obsessed with the speed of light, how soon will we be able to travel the speed of light? Because so many scientists. Never. Never. But wait, they've informed us of certain laws of physics. I'm just wondering, when do we start applying those?
一直都是，一直都是。所以因为我痴迷于光速，我们什么时候才能以光速旅行？因为有那么多科学家。永远不会。永远不会。但等等，他们已经告诉我们某些物理定律了。我只是想知道，我们什么时候开始应用它们？
So breaking the light barrier is not the same thing as breaking the sound barrier. When you heard people say, oh, we'll never fly, and they're just idiots. You know why? Because birds fly, all right? And they're heavier than air. You just haven't figured it out yet. And can you never go faster than sound? Rifle bullets went faster than sound before we had planes.
所以突破光障和突破音障不是一回事。当你听到人们说，哦，我们永远不会飞，他们只是笨蛋。你知道为什么吗？因为鸟会飞，好吧？而且它们比空气重。你们只是还没搞懂而已。难道你就永远不能比声音更快吗？步枪子弹在我们在飞机之前就比声音快了。
So we can make things faster than sound. Just figure it out. The speed of light is not just a good idea as the law of the universe. And if you want to go faster, you have to tunnel through spacetime or have warp drives, which is what all the science fiction ones do. They don't just actually travel faster than light. They try to find some plausible scientific accounting for how they can travel faster than light.
所以我们可以造出比声音还快的东西。只是还没搞懂而已。光速不仅仅是一个好主意，它是宇宙的法则。如果你想走得更快，你必须穿梭于时空，或者拥有曲速引擎，这就是所有科幻小说里所做的。他们不只是实际以比光快的速度旅行。他们试图为如何以比光快的速度旅行找到一些似是而非的科学解释。
And I applaud them all for that. Right. So why, then, after what seems like 100 years is the only means of fast travel in airplane? Because doesn't it seem like by now there should be some kind of improvement on the plane? The only improvement is, you know... Sean, don't get pissed off. I know.
我为他们所有人喝彩。对。那么为什么在似乎过了 100 年之后，快速旅行的唯一手段还是飞机？因为难道不觉得到现在为止飞机应该有某种改进吗？唯一的改进是，你知道的……肖恩，别生气。我知道。
He sounds angry. No, I am not. He's telling me to be aggro today. I am because I'm frustrated that... This is the lightning round, right? I'm going to tell you. Oh, sorry. Good.
他听起来很生气。不，我没有。他今天让我表现得好斗一点。我是因为我感到沮丧……这是闪电轮，对吧？我要告诉你。哦，抱歉。好的。
Here it is. Now somebody else is angry. Some of you are old enough to remember the Concorde SST, Supersonic, right? Yeah, sure. Okay. So that's like the next leap from an ordinary airplane. Do you know something? We didn't have a supersonic commercial plane, but France and England did.
就是这样。现在另一个人生气了。你们当中有些人年龄大到还记得协和超音速客机（Concorde SST），超音速的，对吧？对，当然。好吧。所以那是从普通飞机迈出的下一步。你知道吗？我们没有超音速民航客机，但法国和英国有。
Right. That was the Concorde. And I always wondered why they stopped making them. Oh, you know why? Oh, well, wait a minute. Why can't they fly to Los Angeles? Oh, we're not going to let them because they'll have a sonic boom over the continental United States.
对。那就是协和飞机。我一直想知道他们为什么停止制造了。哦，你知道为什么吗？哦，好吧，等等。为什么他们不能飞往洛杉矶？哦，我们不让，因为他们在美国本土上空会有音爆。
So we cut them off at their kneecaps and said, yeah, you can fly, but you can only cross the ocean. Is that greatly limited the growth of that supersonic industry? And why don't we want a sonic boom over the country? Because it's too scary? What? Well, it can shatter dishes and things and knock them off. The space shuttle did it, though.
所以我们砍断了他们的膝盖骨，说，是的，你能飞，但你只能飞越大洋。这极大地限制了超音速产业的发展吗？为什么我们不希望国家上空出现音爆？因为太吓人了？什么？嗯，它会震碎盘子之类的东西并把它们震落。不过航天飞机做到了。
Well, that's because it's coming in over Florida and it's over a low density area and mostly ocean. So you can do it. You have to understand, Neil, Sean's theory is that if you're high enough, anything's okay. Oh, it's so stupid. So what we really want is hypersonic transportation, where you get to Tokyo in an hour and a half. This would be suborbital.
嗯，那是因为它是从佛罗里达上空进来的，而且是在低密度地区和大部分海洋上空。所以你可以做到。你必须明白，奈尔，肖恩的理论是，如果你飞得够高，什么都行。哦，太蠢了。所以我们真正想要的是高超音速交通，你可以在一个半小时内到达东京。这将是亚轨道的。
I want that. Right. Okay. That's even faster than just the Concorde. You know, if you go suborbital, you are not farther than 45 minutes from any two places anywhere on Earth. Here's the problem. What does it mean that it took you an hour and a half to drive to the airport in another
我想那样。对。好吧。那甚至比单纯的协和飞机还要快。你知道，如果你走亚轨道，你距离地球上任何两个地方都不会超过 45 分钟。问题在这里。花了一个半小时开车去机场，意味着什么？
45 minutes in TSA? So it took you three hours, and then you got to park the car, three hours to take a 45 minute trip to Tokyo. There's a point where, just put me on an airplane where I have internet and movies and I'm fine and I don't need to get there faster. So correct me if I'm wrong. This is what suborbital is. The Earth is rotating at 1,000 miles an hour, right?
在 TSA（安检）又要花 45 分钟？所以你花了三个小时，然后你还得停车，花三个小时去进行一趟去东京的 45 分钟的旅行。在某个时候，只要把我塞进一架有网络有电影的飞机里，我就挺好的，我不需要更快到达那里。所以如果我错了请纠正我。这就是亚轨道。地球以每小时 1,000 英里的速度旋转，对吧？
At the equator. At the equator. Okay. So it's spinning around, let's say 1,000 miles an hour. A plane really looks for interest in math or easy numbers. It goes 500 miles an hour. 500 miles an hour. Right.
在赤道。在赤道。好的。所以它在旋转，比方说每小时 1,000 英里。飞机真的很在意数学或简单的数字。它以每小时 500 英里的速度飞行。每小时 500 英里。对。
So if you're going the direction the Earth is rotating, you're never going to get to that destination. No. You're going to get inside this three mile gravitational bubble, right? Neil, you should know that the teacher told them that on the second night, because he stayed for a second night. We had a wonderful time. Wonderful time.
所以如果你朝着地球旋转的方向飞行，你永远也到不了那个目的地。不对。你会进入这个三英里的引力气泡里面，对吧？奈尔，你应该知道老师在第二天告诉过他们这个，因为他在那里待了第二晚。我们度过了一段美好的时光。美好的时光。
No, no. So if you launch your plane at the equator and you stay in Earth's atmosphere, because it's flying through the Earth's atmosphere, Earth is turning at 1,000 miles an hour. The air is moving at 1,000 miles an hour. The plane is moving at 1,000 miles an hour. Now it goes 500 miles an hour. So it's going 1,500 miles an hour through space. But if you go straight up and you leave this three mile sort of bubble, you then leave
不，不。所以如果你在赤道发射你的飞机，并且你呆在地球的大气层里，因为它是在地球的大气层中飞行，地球以每小时 1,000 英里的速度旋转。空气以每小时 1,000 英里的速度移动。飞机以每小时 1,000 英里的速度移动。现在它以每小时 500 英里的速度飞行。所以它以每小时 1,500 英里的速度在太空中穿行。但如果你笔直向上，离开这三英里左右的气泡，你就离开了
gravitational pull and you can take advantage of that 1,000 mile an hour spin. So they want that 1,000 miles to get a little extra boost to go into orbit around the Earth, and orbital speed is 18,000 miles an hour. So you get a little boost by doing that. If you go back the opposite way, you've got to make up 2,000 miles per hour's worth of speed. So even if you just went straight up like a rocket does, and you leave that... No, it doesn't.
引力，你可以利用那每小时 1,000 英里的自转。所以他们需要那 1,000 英里来获得一点额外的推力，从而进入环绕地球的轨道，而轨道速度是每小时 18,000 英里。所以你这样做能获得一点推力。如果你反方向走，你就得补足相当于每小时 2,000 英里的速度。所以，即使你像火箭那样径直向上发射，然后你离开那个…… 不，其实不是这样的。
In fact, they don't do that. I'm saying if you... No, no, no. Most... Just be clear. It's just something people don't know. Yeah. Most of the energy of a rocket launch is not to go up.
事实上，他们不那样做。我是说如果你…… 不，不，不。大多数…… 明确一点。这只是人们不了解的事情。是的。火箭发射的大部分能量并不是为了往上飞。
It is to go downstream and give it enough sideways speed so that it doesn't fall out of the sky. Wow. So the space shuttle, the space station, they're all going 18,000 miles an hour sideways. That's why mission control, you're now going to execute the role program, and this is the space shuttle now going sideways downstream. We're down... Oh.
而是为了向侧面飞行，赋予它足够的横向速度，这样它就不会从空中掉下来。哇。所以航天飞机、空间站，它们都在以每小时 18,000 英里的速度向侧面飞行。这就是为什么任务控制中心会说，你现在要执行滚转程序，这就是现在向侧面飞行的航天飞机。我们在下…… 哦。
So they're not going up, they're going sideways. That's most of their energy. We think space is up. You know how high up they go? Where do you guys live? Where do you live? LA? Okay.
所以它们不是在往上飞，而是在向侧面飞。这是它们绝大部分的能量消耗。我们以为太空是在上方。你知道它们飞多高吗？你们住在哪里？你们住哪？洛杉矶？好吧。
Yeah. They are less above Earth's surface than the distance of San Francisco from Los Angeles. No, wow. Okay? What's that distance? What's it? How many miles does San Francisco get? It's like four.
是的。它们距离地球表面的高度，甚至小于旧金山到洛杉矶的距离。不会吧，哇。好吗？那是什么距离？是多少？旧金山有多少英里？大概四……
Three hundred miles? Three hundred and fifty miles? Yeah, it's about three. Yeah. Yeah, about three hundred and fifty miles. So two-thirds of that, that's the height that the space shuttle flies. So you can drive that in a few hours. That's not even what the rocket is doing, okay?
三百英里？三百五十英里？对，大概三百。对。对，大概三百五十英里。所以其中三分之二，那就是航天飞机飞行的髙度。所以你开几个小时的车就能到。这甚至都不是火箭在做的事情，好吧？
It's just getting up above the atmosphere because it doesn't have to plow through air. By the way, if we didn't have an atmosphere, it would just go sideways, just launch it sideways, okay? Wow. So once you're above the atmosphere, you're outside the gravitational pull, right? No. The atmosphere? No.
它只是飞到大气层上方，因为它不需要强行穿过空气。顺便说一句，如果我们没有大气层，它就会直接向侧面飞，直接横向发射，好吧？哇。所以一旦你到了大气层上方，你就脱离了引力，对吧？不对。大气层？不对。
The last we checked, Earth is orbited by the moon. The moon feels Earth's gravity, so all astronauts are deep within Earth's gravity. The difference is they're weightless, not because they've left Earth's gravity, but because they are falling towards Earth. So here's the brilliance of Isaac Newton. You want to mind something? Mind blowing? Here it is.
我们最后一次确认时，地球是有月球环绕的。月球能感受到地球的引力，所以所有的宇航员都深深地处在地球的引力范围之内。区别在于他们处于失重状态，不是因为他们离开了地球引力，而是因为他们在向地球坠落。所以这就是艾萨克·牛顿的 brilhante（才华）。你想听点震撼的吗？震撼心灵的？就是这个。
Isaac Newton. He said, hmm, there's the moon in orbit around the Earth and I drop an apple and it falls straight to Earth. Is this the same thing or is it two different things going on? And then he had a thought experiment. This is why he's Isaac Newton and we're the rest of us. He said, suppose I have a mountain and I have a cannon and I fire a cannonball from that mountain horizontally.
艾萨克·牛顿。他说，嗯，那里有环绕地球运行的月球，而我扔下一个苹果，它径直落向地面。这是同一回事，还是发生了两件不同的事？然后他做了一个思想实验。这就是为什么他是艾萨克·牛顿而我们是其余的凡人。他说，假设我有一座山，我有一门大炮，我从那座山上水平发射一颗炮弹。
It'll go out a few hundred yards and hit the ground, right? Suppose I fire it faster. It'll go farther along Earth's surface before it hits the ground. Let me keep increasing the speed and it falls farther and farther away from you. There must be a speed where it falls so far away from you, it completely goes around the Earth and hits you in the back of the head. Well, at that point, just duck and the ball continues in what we call orbit. And that entire time it was falling towards Earth.
它会飞出几百码然后击中地面，对吧？假设我以更快的速度发射它。它会在击中地面之前沿着地球表面飞得更远。让我继续增加速度，它就会落得离你越来越远。一定存在这样一个速度，它落得离你如此之远，以至于它完全绕过了地球并砸中你的后脑勺。好吧，在那一刻，只要低头躲开，球就会继续沿着我们所谓的轨道运行。而在这整个过程中，它其实一直在向地球坠落。
The difference is it fell by the exact amount that Earth curved away from it. I try to throw knowledge at Jason from a distance and it never hits him in the head. Never ever hit him in the head. Don't just think about this is, well, this is profound. Think about this. Yeah, it's incredible. You're going sideways so fast that when you've dropped a foot, when you've dropped a foot, Earth's curvature curves away from you by a foot.
区别在于，它下落的距离刚好等于地球曲率远离它的距离。我试图从远处把知识砸向杰森，但它从来没砸中过他的头。从来没砸中过他的头。不要只是觉得这只是，嗯，这很深刻。想想看。是的，这太不可思议了。你向侧面飞得如此之快，以至于当你下落了一英尺时，当你下落了一英尺，地球的曲率正好也远离了你一英尺。
So you never catch up to it. You never catch up to the Earth. Thus is the definition of an orbit and you're in free fall the entire time, like cutting the cables of an elevator falling straight down, except you happen to have sideways motion. And so falling straight down means you never hit the Earth. Neil, there's a lot of debate about this because I know you got to go, but there's a lot of debate about it. Do you agree?
所以你永远追不上它。你永远追不上地球。这就是轨道的定义，而且你自始至终都处于自由落体状态，就像剪断了直线下坠的电梯缆绳一样，只不过你恰好拥有横向运动。所以径直下落意味着你永远不会撞击地球。尼尔，关于这一点有很多争论，因为我知道你得走了，但这里面有很多争论。你同意吗？
A lot of people say that the best season of Will and Grace was season five. Do you think that that's true? Because... Okay, wait. I know you have to go, but I really... This is the biggest one I wanted to talk to you about and we can just plow right through it. What's that?
很多人说《威尔与格蕾丝》最好的季度是第五季。你觉得这是真的吗？因为…… 好吧，等等。我知道你得走了，但我真的很…… 这是我最想跟你聊的话题，我们可以直接开门见山。什么事？
I want to talk about aliens. I love them. I want to meet them. Nobody doesn't love the aliens. I'm all the... Okay, sure. I would be with them. And if not, will we?
我想聊聊外星人。我爱死他们了。我想见到他们。没有人不爱外星人。我完全…… 好吧，当然。我会和他们在一起的。如果不的话，我们会吗？
Because... And this is the other follow-up thing. I watched... I'm like an obsessed documentarian about aliens in space and all that flying area 51. So Bob Lazar has this documentary. Did you see it? It was about... He claimed he had or has some element that is not of this Earth, which alien craft is
因为…… 这是另一个后续的问题。我看了…… 我就像一个对外星人和太空以及所有那些51区飞行事件着迷的纪录片迷。所以鲍勃·拉扎尔有个纪录片。你看过吗？讲的是…… 他声称他拥有或曾经拥有某种不属于这个地球的元素，而外星飞船就是
made up of. Do you know this? Yeah, I've heard of these claims, but they don't offer it to laboratories to... I mean, here's the thing. If we're visited by aliens, why... Maybe we've been visited. Okay? Maybe.
由这种元素构成的。你知道这个吗？是的，我听说过这些说法，但他们并没有把样品提供给实验室来…… 我的意思是，事情是这样的。如果外星人造访过我们，为什么…… 也许我们被造访过。好吗？也许吧。
I think we have. Okay. Let me offer you countervailing thought regarding that. Do you realize we collectively upload a billion photographs and videos to the Internet per day? Per day. Every day, we upload more photos and videos to the Internet that existed in the world in the first hundred years of photography.
我认为我们被造访过。好吧。我来向你提出一个相反的观点。你知道我们全人类平均每天向互联网上传多少亿张照片和视频吗？每天。每天，我们上传到互联网上的照片和视频数量，比摄影技术诞生头一百年里世界上存在的照片和视频总数还要多。
We have photos of extremely rare phenomena, like buses tumbling in hurricanes or in tornadoes. In the day, you wouldn't say, oh, that's interesting, let me go home and get my camera and film this. No, everybody's got a camera. Until we had... Until everybody had a camera, you had all these reports of people getting abducted. Where's the photo of the craft? Why is it that your best evidence for aliens visiting is fuzzy Navy video?
我们有极其罕见现象的照片，比如在飓风或龙卷风中翻滚的公交车。在过去，你不会说，“哦，这真有趣，让我回家拿相机把它拍下来。”不，现在每个人都有相机。在拥有…… 在每个人都有相机之前，你有所有这些关于人们被绑架的报道。飞船的照片在哪里？为什么你们声称外星人造访的最有力证据是一段模糊不清的海军视频？
Yeah, I know. I get that. Why is that your best evidence? What do you think about the Navy video, Neil? What do you think? I don't know what it is. That's why it's you, an identified flying object. But in this documentary, they say, you know, what you're saying, why wouldn't aliens come
是的，我知道。我明白这一点。为什么这就是你们最有力证据？尼尔，你对海军视频怎么看？你怎么看？我不知道那是什么。这就是为什么它是 UFO（不明飞行物）。但在纪录片里，他们说，你知道的，正如你所说，为什么外星人不下来
down and greet us and why don't they say hello? Because and the explanation is they are afraid of us and they are afraid of what we would do to them. So the common denominator of all conspiracy theorists is when they don't have the data, they have to invent something to bridge the gap in their data. So I'm not bridging any gap. I'm saying everybody is a recorder. Where's the evidence of these visitations?
跟我们打招呼，为什么他们不说声你好？因为，解释是他们害怕我们，他们害怕我们会对他们做什么。所以所有阴谋论者的共同点是，当他们没有数据时，他们必须凭空捏造一些东西来填补他们数据中的空白。所以我没有填补任何空白。我是说每个人都是记录者。这些造访的证据在哪里？
Why is it that crop circles only happen when nobody's looking? All right. Why? Are the aliens just shy? Okay. Aliens are shy. Then maybe they don't want to be disturbed by us. Fine.
为什么麦田怪圈只在没人看的时候出现？好了。为什么？难道外星人只是害羞？好吧。外星人很害羞。那也许他们不想被我们打扰。好吧。
Okay. But when the aliens finally come who are not shy, I don't think they're only going to show up in fuzzy Navy video. So let's let's close with this. First of all, we do have one thing in common. You and I, you have over a dozen honorary doctorates because of all the knowledge in your brain while I have over a dozen doctors treating the condition of my brain. So what are the scientists, what are the scientists getting right right now and what
但是，当那些不害羞的外星人最终到来时，我不认为他们只会出现在一段模糊的海军视频里。所以让我们以此来作个结。首先，我们确实有一个共同点。你和我，你因为你大脑中的所有知识而拥有十几项荣誉博士学位，而我有十多位医生在治疗我大脑的病情。那么，关于新冠肺炎和全球变暖，科学家们现在做对了什么，又
are they getting wrong as far as COVID and global warming? Okay. So one of the challenges is when you model climate, it's very messy. There's a lot of, there's the heat from the sun. There's the uptake of carbon dioxide in the ocean. There's the spewing of carbon dioxide. It's very complicated. And so what we need is training on how to think about models presented by scientists
做错了什么？好的。所以其中一个挑战是，当你对气候进行建模时，情况非常混乱。有很多因素，有来自太阳的热量。有海洋对二氧化碳的吸收。有二氧化碳的排放。这非常复杂。所以我们需要的是关于如何看待科学家提出的模型的培训，
because every model has an uncertainty range. And so you present the model and the uncertainty range to lawmakers and to policy people and say, here's the best available knowledge. Now find a political solution to this. You don't say, take the politics and say, oh, we deny what your scientists are saying. What is that? What are you doing? This is a recipe for disaster.
因为每个模型都有一个不确定性范围。因此，你把模型和不确定性范围呈献给立法者和政策制定者，并说：“这是目前掌握的最佳知识。现在，请为此寻找一个政治解决方案。”你不能说，把政治带进来，然后说，“哦，我们否认你们科学家所说的话。”那是什么？你在干什么？这是自取灭亡的秘诀。
And as I've said, I think I tweeted this recently. Every disaster movie begins with what? People ignoring the warnings of a scientist. Right, right, right. Of course. But it goes to what you were saying before. As we know, and whether people want to admit it or not, we're constantly driven by geopolitical goals, et cetera, personal.
正如我所说，我想我最近发了一条推文。每一部灾难电影都是从什么开始的？人们忽视了科学家的警告。对，对，对。当然。但这回到了你之前所说的话。正如我们所知，无论人们是否愿意承认，我们不断受到地缘政治目标等因素以及个人因素的驱使。
And I accept that. But just don't, don't put those in front of objectively true scientific information. Because then you're arguing a house of cards and nothing good will ever come of that. So maybe we need to retrain people to understand what science is, how and why it works. What is an objective truth? What does it mean to be convinced by something? Why do we have people who think Earth is flat? Why?
我接受这一点。但只是不要，不要把这些置于客观真实的科学信息之上。因为那样的话，你就是在争论一个危如累卵的纸牌屋，而且绝不会有什么好结果。所以也许我们需要重新培训人们去理解什么是科学，它是如何以及为什么工作的。什么是客观真理？被某事说服意味着什么？为什么会有觉得地球是平的人？为什么？
I know, it's crazy. Where is the failure? Do you think global warming is the next quote pandemic that we're going to be dealing with? It's an existential crisis that's happening on a longer time scale than the pandemic is. So the time frames over which things have been happening with regard to the pandemic are rapid. They're happening outwardly, all right? And we all need to behave coherently to fight it.
我知道，这太疯狂了。问题出在哪里？你认为全球变暖会是我们要面对的下一个所谓的“大流行”吗？这是一场生存危机，它发生的时间尺度比大流行要长。因此，与大流行相关的事情发生的时间框架是迅速的。它们正在公开发生，对吧？我们都需要采取一致的行动来对抗它。
It's like saying, oh, well, some states wants to open before other states. And the, my favorite analog to that is that's like opening a peeing section of the pool. Okay? You just go to that section of the pool and pee there. Here's the problem. The virus is not visible. Okay? If, by the way, if your pee turned purple in contact with the chlorine, everybody would
这就像是说，“哦，好吧，有些州想比其他州更早解封。”而我对此最喜欢的类比是，这就好比在游泳池里开辟一个“撒尿区”。好吧？你只要去游泳池的那个区域并在那里撒尿就行了。问题在于：病毒是看不见的。好吧？顺便说一句，如果你的尿液在接触到氯气时变成紫色，每个人
be called out for that. Okay? Right. Instantly. But you can't see the virus. And so people think they're somehow immune to it. But if a monster came out of the woods, grab people at the rate that COVID deaths are happening, grab them and bit their head off and spill their bloods in the streets.
都会因此被抓包。好吧？没错。立刻就会。但你看不到病毒。所以人们认为自己某种程度上对它免疫。但如果森林里走出一个怪物，以新冠死亡发生的速率抓走人们，抓住他们并咬断他们的头，把他们的血洒在街上，
The coordinated effort in the world to get rid of this creature would know no bounds. Okay? Right, right. So here we have a virus that you can't see and somehow you think is not going to affect you. This is a problem with human cognition and human, again, it's relates to the Serengeti. Is it big and it can eat you? I'm scared of it.
世界上消除这个怪物的协同努力将是无止境的。好吧？对，对。所以这里我们有一种你看不见的病毒，而你不知怎么的认为它不会影响你。这是人类认知和人类思维的一个问题，再次强调，这与塞伦盖蒂平原有关。它很大而且能吃掉你吗？我害怕它。
Otherwise, I don't know. I'm not scared. Okay? Even though if I should be. There are resources that the government uses and the money and the power to solve this problem almost immediately when they could do that with anything. Very good point. And so for me, it was a shot across our bow.
否则，我不知道。我不害怕。好吧？即使我本该害怕。政府拥有资源、金钱和权力，几乎可以立即解决这个问题，尽管他们本可以对任何事都这样做。很好的观点。所以对我来说，这是一个警钟。
Think if hostile aliens came and visited, we should all coordinate. Put down your weapons against each other because they're after humans, and we are all human. And it could be the greatest peace inducing force there ever was for all humans to realize they have a common enemy. So my point is this is a practice run. Global warming is happening on a slower timescale than weeks, yet we all have to coordinate. You can't say, well, if China is not going to fix the air, why should I, when air molecules don't need passports to go from one country to another, neither do water molecules and
想想如果有敌对的外星人来访，我们都应该协同一致。放下彼此之间的武器，因为它们的目标是人类，而我们全都是人类。对于所有意识到自己拥有共同敌人的全人类来说，这可能是曾经存在过的最强大的促进和平的力量。所以我的观点是，这是一次排练。全球变暖发生的时间尺度比几周要慢，然而我们仍然需要协调一致。你不能说，“好吧，如果中国不清理空气，凭什么我要清理，”当空气分子不需要护照就能从一个国家传到另一个国家时，水分子和
pollution molecules. So at some point we have to think globally as one species and I don't see that happening anytime soon. You know, we did, there was an initial big response to this pandemic and when people were, you know, everybody's locked down, all of a sudden nobody knew what to do. But it's about that sustained interest in it. And it's somebody, I remember somebody say, it's such a, we're experiencing such an American lockdown that eventually people are like, no, I'm kind of bored of it now.
污染分子同样不需要。所以总有一天，我们要作为一个物种从全球层面去思考，而我短期内看不到这种情况发生。你知道，我们确实，对这场大流行病最初有一个巨大的反应，当人们被，你知道的，每个人都居家隔离时，突然之间谁也不知道该怎么办了。但关键在于对它的持续关注。而且有人，我记得有人说过，我们正在经历一种非常美式的高度隔离，以至于最终人们会觉得，“不，我现在觉得有点无聊了。”
Yeah. Right. It's not headlines anymore. It's not really, yeah, it's not really that interesting to me anymore. And the problem is, is that what happens is once again, certain interests, special interests, they start to outweigh the value of this sustained interest in overcoming this. So let me, let me be devil's advocate here for the moment. So you're a restaurant worker and now restaurants are closed by law, okay?
是的。没错。它不再是头条新闻了。它真的不再是，是的，对我来说真的没那么有趣了。而问题在于，一旦发生这种情况，某些利益集团，特殊利益集团，又开始压倒克服这一困难所需的持续关注的价值。所以，请允许我在此充当一下魔鬼代言人。假设你是一名餐馆员工，现在餐馆依法关闭了，好吧？
You're a bus boy, you're a whatever. And so the problem is we didn't go into this with a plan to give people hope and expectations for how they will return to normal. Right. Right. So the governmental handling of the scientific information, you know, in hindsight, it's easy to say that it was botched. I don't know how to do it differently.
你是一个杂工，或者别的什么。所以问题在于，我们在进入这场危机时，并没有制定一个计划，来给人们提供希望以及关于他们将如何恢复正常的预期。对。对。所以政府对科学信息的处理，事后看来，可以说是一团糟。我不知道该如何做得更好。
I don't have a silver bullet here, but I can tell you the next time this happens, we got to have a rollout plan and the factory floors, factory, you go into, into virus mode and people separate and the production goes down a little, but it doesn't go to zero. Right. Okay. And you have people shifts and people work this eight hour shift and that eight hour shift so that they're not right on top of each other there. We didn't have any of those plans and that's what you need.
我这里没有什么灵丹妙药，但我可以告诉你，下次再发生这种情况时，我们必须有一个推出计划，工厂车间，工厂，你进入病毒模式，人们分开，产量下降一点，但不会降到零。好吧。而且你要实行轮班制，让人们在这个八小时班次工作，在那个八小时班次工作，这样他们就不会紧紧挨在一起了。我们当时没有任何这些计划，而这正是你所需要的。
Do you think that we need to get ready for this happening, not necessarily with Corona or a different Corona or whatever it is that this is, this is our new reality. It's called disaster preparedness and the problem is no one wants to spend money on it. If it's not an obvious threat. And let me get back to the CO2 warming the planet. If CO2 were purple and you'd walk by a car and you saw purple stuff coming out of purples too pretty, if it was sludgy brown and you see this coming out and you see it coming
你认为我们需要为再次发生这种情况做好准备吗？不一定是新冠，或者是另一种新冠病毒，无论它是什么，这就是我们的新现实。这被称为灾难防备，而问题在于没有人愿意在这上面花钱，如果它不是一个显而易见的威胁的话。让我回到二氧化碳使地球变暖的话题。如果二氧化碳是紫色的，当你走过一辆汽车时，你看到紫色物质从紫色太美了里喷出来，如果它是泥泞的棕色，你看到它从
out of smokes and you see that and it just stayed in the air, you would say, we got to stop this. Right. This is hurting me. This is coming, but it's invisible and you can't smell it. And so we're very ostrich like in this regard. Yeah. Well, Neil, I know you got to run.
烟囱里冒出来，你看到它出来，并且它就停留在空中，你会说：“我们必须阻止这一切。这在伤害我。这正在发生，”但它是看不见的，你也闻不到它。所以在这方面我们非常像鸵鸟。是的。好吧，尼尔，我知道你得走了。
I'm a huge fan of science. I'm a huge fan of facts and I'm a huge fan of the good people and you are all three of those things. Yeah. Thank you so much for being here today. You love facts. You've had like three or four facts machines in your life, haven't you? Yeah, for sure.
我是科学的超级粉丝。我是事实的超级粉丝，我也是好人的超级粉丝，而你兼具这三者。是的。非常感谢你今天来到这里。你热爱事实。你这一生有过三四台“事实制造机”，对吧？是的，当然。
And I just, I still use it. I get like auditions from it and like, yeah, I got to refill it actually. No, but Neil, thank you so much. Yeah. Please keep sharing your knowledge in the generous and interesting way that you do. Well, thanks for that. And I'd love to come back on. I mean, when you, if all your other guests say, no, I'm never doing that again, you
而且我只是，我还在用它。我会从中获得一些试镜机会，而且，是的，其实我还得给它加墨。不，但是尼尔，非常感激。是的。请继续以你那种慷慨而有趣的方式分享你的知识。嗯，谢谢你的夸奖。我很乐意再来。我是说，当你，如果你所有的其他嘉宾都说，“我再也不干了，”你
can call me back. Listen, I was going to say I can't speak for the other guys, but I can. I would say we, I know that we, that we would all be delighted to have a part two with you. Yeah. If you'd be willing to do it. Because the universe is vast. And I also want to say just, if I can spend just one moment fanboying, you guys make really fun movies and they're just, for me, a little bit of escapism in it.
可以随时叫我回来。听着，我本来想说我不能代表其他人，但我能。我会说我们，我知道我们，我们所有人都会非常高兴能有与你的第二部分访谈。是的。如果你愿意的话。因为宇宙是浩瀚的。而且我也想说，如果我可以花一点点时间来化身粉丝，你们拍的电影真的很有趣，对我来说，里面有一点点逃避现实的意味。
Movie. Yeah. So just keep it going. We need it. We need the diversion. We need the escape. Yeah. Yeah.
电影。是的。所以请继续拍下去。我们需要它。我们需要这种转移视线的东西。我们需要这种逃离。是的。是的。
The levity. Oh, thanks, pal. Which would be the opposite of gravity. Levity. Yeah. Way to bring it back around. Beautiful. Right there.
轻松的时刻。哦，谢谢你，伙计。这正是“重力”（gravity）的反义词。幽默感（Levity）。是的。真会把话题绕回来。太完美了。就在这儿。
Well, thank you very much. Thanks. All right, guys. We'll see you later. Bye. Isn't he like, for me, I, I don't know why I have that chip in my brain that is endlessly fascinated by that stuff. I could talk for hours and hours and hours about all of those sub topics.
嗯，非常感谢。谢谢。好了，伙计们。我们回头见。再见。难道他不……对我来说，我，我不知道为什么我大脑里有那种芯片，对那些东西有着无尽的迷恋。我可以连续几个小时、几个小时、几个小时地谈论所有这些子话题。
Same, same here. I'm, I'm incredible. The one thing I wanted to ask him, and I could ask you guys the same, because I don't know what my answer would be about it either. Do you think if you went up to space and then you came back down, if you just did like one lap and you came, would you be like, exhausted, depressed, just literally to get up so high to like look back down at the earth, then come back down, everything would be so anticlimactic. I wonder if it would be, I think more people need to think like that, like you're saying
我也是，我也是。我，我太不可思议了。我一直想问他的一件事，我也同样可以问你们，因为我也不知道自己对此会作何回答。你觉得如果你去了太空然后又返回地面，如果你只是绕了一圈就回来，你会不会觉得筋疲力尽、沮丧，仅仅是为了飞得那么高去回头看一眼地球，然后又返回地面，一切都变得如此虎头蛇尾。我在想它会不会是这样，我觉得更多的人需要像你一样去思考，就像你说的，
Jason is, well, and any astronaut I've heard in an interview or anything, they say the exact same thing you're saying. You go up there, you get a picture and an image of the world we live in and you realize how small it is. And every astronaut that has experienced that has said, you realize that we're all the same and that why can't we figure out how to get along? You know what I mean? And, and I think every astronaut always says, asks it like, what is that experience when
杰森，以及我听过采访或任何节目的任何宇航员，他们说的都跟你说的一模一样。你去了那里，你会对我们生活的世界有一个画面和印象，然后你就会意识到它是多么渺小。每一个经历过这一点的宇航员都说过，你会意识到我们都是一样的，为什么我们不能弄清楚如何和平相处？你知道我的意思吗？而且，而且我认为每个宇航员总是会问，当你在太空中时，那种体验是什么样的？而他们会说这简直妙不可言。
you're up in space and they say it's out of this world? Oh, nice. Well, you just dropped out for a little bit. Sorry, what happened? There you are. You're back. Trust me, it was pretty good, Sean. Well, did you guys learn anything today?
哦，太好了。好吧，你刚才信号中断了一小会儿。抱歉，怎么了？你在这儿。你回来了。相信我，刚才讲得挺好的，肖恩。好吧，你们今天学到东西了吗？
So much. How badly do we need to have him? He should be, we should have him on like once every three months just to keep us, you know, what's going on with the cosmos? What's happening? Right, right. When Neil said, every single day, we upload over a billion photos. So it goes, I mean, the four of us.
学到太多了。我们有多需要把他请来？我们应该每三个月把他请来一次，好让我们随时了解，你知道的，宇宙正在发生什么？有什么最新动态？对，对。当尼尔说，我们每天上传超过十亿张照片。所以这就意味着，我是说我们这四个人。
He loves to post. Will's a real poster. I know. I just, I just. Tag it. Post it. Like it. Will, do you tweet still?
他喜欢发帖。威尔是个真正的发帖狂。我知道。我只是，我只是。打个标签。发个帖子。点个赞。威尔，你还在发推特吗？
Rarely. Rarely. Yeah, he does. Will's with a very frequent, it's like, hey, lines are long at Starbys today. It's like, shut up, Will. It's my right to call it Starbys. I wanted to ask Neil if he starts his day off at Starbucks. Wow.
很少。很少。是的，他会的。威尔非常频繁地发推，就像是，“嘿，今天星巴克的队伍好长啊。”就像是，“闭嘴吧，威尔。”我叫它星巴克是我的权利。我想问问尼尔他是不是以星巴克开始一天的。哇。
Wow. He probably pays with Starbucks. Do you guys get that? Do you guys get that? Yeah. No, I got it. Sean, do you get your own joke? Do you even get your own joke?
哇。他大概是用星巴克付账的吧。你们懂这个梗吗？你们懂吗？没有，我懂。肖恩，你自己懂自己的笑话吗？你甚至懂你自己的笑话吗？
All right. Let's let our listener get to dinner or whatever. I love the idea that all our, anybody who listens to our podcast is going, is rushing to a meal. We have to book our soul listener at some point. That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying. Oh, thank you, Sean.
好啦。让我们让听众去吃晚饭或干别的什么吧。我喜欢这种想法，所有听我们播客的人都在急急忙忙地赶去吃一顿饭。我们得在某个时候预约我们唯一的听众。这就是我想说的。这就是我想说的。哦，谢谢你，肖恩。
All right. Love you guys. Love you guys. Love you too. Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart.
好了。爱你们。爱你们。我也爱你们。再见。再见。再见。聪明。
What? Smart. What? Smart. glass. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
什么？聪明。什么？聪明。玻璃。这个单集目前还没有评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。